want your children to learn how to code
this summer maybe they want to learn
there's an app for them yeah two local
entrepreneurs started a coding app and
their goal is to reach lower income and
foster children Candace Charles joining
us live this morning with the game
that's getting kids excited about coding
Candace good morning to you
good morning YouTube good morning folks
well you may have heard of it Minecraft
it is the game scribble Labs is using to
teach children how to cope now squirrel
Labs provides a safe environment for
children to learn coding from experts in
the field there are live sessions for
one-on-one training in-game challenges
and this summer a coding Camp it'll be
three days a week participants will get
a mini craft excuse me a Minecraft
challenge eventually the solution and
inactivity the apples created to help
low-income and foster children gain
access to the world of computer science
very scaffolded learning from start to
finish and really the goal is to give
you know underserved and foster kids
um one a way to access that information
it's very valuable right I mean coding
is something that could change their
lives if they're able to learn that and
have access to that and also it gives
them some stability
[Music]
now there is an application to verify
income but again the app is free to low
income and foster children it's 25 bucks
though for the paid subscription and
that money goes towards the services for
the low income foster children the
summer camp starts on May 23rd again
there will be three live sessions a week
but leading up to it there'll be two
live streams a week and of course you
can find out more details about how to
access the app which is available all
the time of course the summer camp again
starts on May 23rd but of course more
details for you on our website
8newsnow.com for now live in The
Newsroom I'm Candace Charles eight is
now I'm gonna start doing what Dustin
was doing on the screen that little
dance he was doing and it was like this
on the thing with the glasses do you
think that'll help you learn to code
yeah I think it's the cool yeah so I'm
going to be recording this it's a good
program Candace thank you very much